- Thank you chairman.
Well, just now we have,
the previous panelists
has a brief the history
of arms control.
I want to focus on what's going on today
and actually my understanding
the arms control regime
and being undermined by the
junior Bush administration.
When he incorporated nuclear
corporation, with the India
and the, since then this arms control
regime did not achieve
anything substantial, actually
during Clinton's period
and the arms control
regime make a big progress.
And for instance, at that time
and China and the Clinton
administration revised the
the MTCR and China and joined that
that program and all of the
other, they linked this missiles
and the war had together and make a one
after another progress, but
it seems, and junior Bush came
to power and they hold an
international arms control regime
stop making progress.
Well, what I want to focus
on, I want talking about the
since there's a column about a model I3
I want to talk, talk a little
bit about the bilateralism
and the Multilateralism of arms control.
And now this is some people argue.
They say that, look at that.
When Trump administration
abandoned multilateralism
on North Korea creates
a nuclear issues and
they make progress.
And so six party towers advocated
by China as a multilateralism
achieved nothing
big six party towers
won town for years
and it went nowhere
and finally it stopped.
And it would trump abandoned
at that multilateralism
and talk with the North Korean director.
She has said, you know
usually the American rejected
to have a bilateral toggle
with the North Korea, but not use a trump
administration say, I only
want to have bilateral talk.
So this issue becomes China, South Korea
US South Korea, North Korea, South Korea
and then US and Japan, US
China, and a US South Korea.
Is a purely, becomes a
byline for a discussion.
They said, bilateral
discussion, final resolved it.
and really unexpected in
the US North Korea summit.
You can believe it.
And so there's a debate in China.
I don't know how about the
whether it is the same similar situation
in the other countries.
People say, Hey, and the, in the future
the arms control should be focused
on multi-lateral approach
or bilateral approach.
Some people argue that
a bilateral approach is
a more effective than multi-lateral.
Some would argue that
have a pilot for first
and then put them together
and merge into a multilateral.
Well, there's a lot of ideas,
but for my understanding
this is a debate in China.
At least I think the
misleading people understand
that the core of the issue
(inaudible) the nuclear weapons.
And the actually no matter
the Trump administration
and adopt a bilateral or
multilateral approach. North Korea
already decided to stop a nuclear test.
The reason is that there, the goal
of their deterrence is a very low
because of the nuclear weapons
the base of a North Korea
as a regime security.
So they just want to make
the regime can survive.
So how did they link it
to the nuclear weapons?
It means that as long as US
do not launch a war against North Korea
they can survive. Leave
alone the domestic factors.
So in that case, North Korea Alrighty
prepared to have the last nuclear test
and then want to say,
sit down to talk and to
release all of these sanctions.
So when Trump administration
said, okay, I won't talk
to you if you stop actually
now square already prepared
for that because you
just record what I said.
And so now we find that
why they're a country.
I mean, it's nuclear
power to abandon them and
their nuclear weapons
closely relate to one thing.
It's the redeem security.
You see North Korea do
not abandon the, their nuclear
weapons because of when the
apartheid regime a
handout, the, the, the, the
the power to the blacks right?
So then there's no any security though.
And Regime securities threat
to the black, South,
South Africa government.
And so they abandoned after that the
the Soviet union and
these independence days
they think they can get
a security protection
from international community.
They can get lists
and some countries think
that they can join the NATO
the get a security protection,
nuclear umbrella from US.
So they think that there's
no danger to their security
especially this country went
through the democratization, right?
So when they attacked this
Western democratic system
and then people never think of the feeling
stress will a threat threaten to their,
the domestic regimes.
So they gave up the nuclear
weapons. Libya the same Gaddafi
never think he will be toppled
down if he gave up the nuclear
weapons, but after Libya
people's mentality changed,
they say, Hey, wait a minute.
You will give up nuclear weapons.
If you're enemy of the
U S you face the danger
over the war from the launched
by the U S and then that
war will destroy you.
Now, the country that
destroyed your regime.
So nowadays from my
understanding, the arms control
isn't no longer like during
the cold war only related
to the national security,
actually after the Gulf war.
And I don't think any
country faces that danger
being annexed by anyone
the international charter
international community
has a prevent any kind of
annexation of the other States
but no one can guarantee
the regime security.
So the why now, from I
understand now the arms
control already face a new situation
from what we familiar with
that during the cold war.
Okay. So in my book, the
inertia of the history
and China and the world
and the rest of 10 years
I think it will be published
is already translated
in English, by Oxford
and the will come out the
second half of this year.
And in that book, I focused in 2013
I predict that North Korea
is going to stop nuclear test
but it never give up nuclear weapons.
The reason is that the weapons
the base of the regime security
if you're gathering them
nuclear weapons, they say, Hey
the regime will be topple that.
So my understanding now this is
we must have concern
the further arms control and the ever
we want these countries to
give up the nuclear weapons.
We must be talking
about how to guarantee
their regime security.
Unfortunately like
these countries, you run
under the North Korea, the
Western countries say, Hey
for the sake of a political
correctness, we cannot
even when we privately promise
we guarantee the security
regime security.
But if we cannot see that,
but for these countries
they say, Hey, we need
to say publicly to the
to the public and make
everyone knows that you
do not want topple down the regime.
So this is what we're facing.
Second it's about a Harbor, the
arm, the regime of the arms.
Non-proliferation, my
understanding nonproliferation
regime is being undermined, like I said
from the junior boost period.
And I think it will be
further undermined by the
Trump administration
because this administration
have no interest in arms control.
They don't think that this regime
the arm arms control regime,
a community has any meaning.
And that I don't mean
that they, because of they
they have different
mentality and they do not
fear about the danger of war
but Trump really gave the first priority
to economic interests
for, for these government.
They don't think any security interests
should be overwhelmed,
the economic injuries
Since they gave us first
a priority to the economic interests.
I don't think
that they want to spend
effort, time and energy
on this issue.
Well, all of us agree
arms control regime is a multilateral.
And you need the leadership,
especially for nuclear weapons.
And the US have to
undertake the leadership.
If us Do not entertain the
leadership who can replace that
who can function like a leader.
So my understanding neither China
or the Russians as able to play that role.
So that means we're going
to have a no leadership
for the further arms control community
and without the leadership,
how can we make progress?
I think this is just related
to what we'll discussed yesterday
and during the cold war.
And we're so lucky, like
Professor Krepon said.
And Soviet Union and the USA provide
a joint leadership, even the
confront against the everything
but I don't know why
that works so closely.
They provide a Gian
the leadership for the non-proliferation.
Unfortunately today we
don't have it to America
we don't have D2.
And who will, how can we
get a collective leadership
or for these are the
arms control, the regime.
And from my understanding,
that's a very difficult.
So on this point, I
will say at this moment
if we want to have this regime of resuming
it's an energy like the
Clinton's period and we still
can only wait for something to happen.
And to US, you have a new leadership.
They have interesting arms control.
They, since this serious,
this related to the security
of the whole world for
the 7 million population
on the earth, and only the
really concern they're serious
but if they can start, Hey
the money is more serious than this year.
And I doubt the last thing
I want to say is that, now
the arms control for myself
I totally agree with that.
Nikolai and these arms
control can no longer limit it
within the nuclear issue regime.
It should expand to other fields.
The reason is that because
the nuclear weapons
that guaranteed the basic
security for the whole world
that means there's no
danger of the global war.
Meanwhile and the countries,
especially for major powers
becomes a brave to attack each other
on the website, on the internet.
So the cyber war actually
already fought everyday.
Now, my situation is that,
how can we prevent this kind
of a cyber war, separate attack
escalating into something dangerous?
I don't mean that it is well
exaggerated to nuclear war
but then if we do not have
the arms control on this
this will becomes a big problem.
And that actually like a Clinton said
this wiper word is a primitive society.
There's no any sufficient
international law
or regulation to govern this area.
So that's really what we need.
The last point is that
and how can we make the major powers
to cooperate with other arms control.
And first we need to advocating
or the looking for the common
interest shared by them.
If the major powers do not
recognize there is a common
or shared interest
you can hardly expect them
to cooperate with each other.
No, no reason, no, no
no engine to driving
them to work together.
And so at this moment,
from my understanding
and because the word has a heavily rely
on the digital economy and
because the word heavily
rely on the, the, the
the internet already
becomes a of electricity.
It's not only not like
a nuclear weapon the
for the military for a national secret
but for the life, for everything.
So these area and the actually should
we have a lot of shared interests in the
in this field and in this, how
can we cooperate each other?
My understanding you can
never have avarice and ego.
That's a politically correct
with, because of this.
Abraham is the
the eco sovereignty
adopted by the UN charter.
So people say, Hey, they
politically this a principle.
That's true.
But when you come to a
corporation, you need a leadership.
That means some country
must have a more ego
than there should be
more equal than others.
Otherwise they won't
provide the leadership.
Leadership has a cost.
They have to pay for it.
And so in that way, my understanding the
this industry team, we
at least the need is
neither that acuity only
among the major powers
make the major part feel.
We are few countries that are equal
and then talking about
the shared interest.
They will work with each other.
And the finally, I will
say, at least at this moment
how much we can advocate
in multilateralism
as a principle to governing
all major foreign policy.
I don't know.
At the least
and a white house never feel awkward
or the have any difficult
to public say we to
not like the multilateralism.
Not even
you have (inaudible) governments, though
for the major powers at the least
they see the multilateralism
is a cracked, unilaterally is
a wrong. Now, even he correct politically.
Now people feel, they do
not feel shame to say no
we don't lie to the multilateralism.
So how can we make a multilateralism?
It's a political
internationally political
correctness they see is
is a very important at this moment.
Thank you.